my first time actually meeting my
brother Gabby Lee in person properly for
a lot of you a couple years now I'm
looking at my bro on that Instagram and
he's saying she didn't know my words son
I'm feeling you know with what you
saying and when you realize you actually
talking to your phone
and you snap back into reality you
understand that the level of captivating
energy that he has is profound
and I think that's the reason why he's
able to have all of us in this room and
I think that's the reason why so many
people has been able to benefit from
watching him speak whistling to him
speak understanding what he speaks so
I'm saying over this
to let it be known that why y'all giving
me all my flowers on my birthday we
gonna give garyvee his
flowers right now too I got one simple
thing to say let this be very
clear love
I'm defeated